Tucker Carlson is in Moscow to interview
Vladimir Putin we're in Moscow tonight
we're here to interview the president of
Russia Vladimir Putin will be doing that
soon almost 3 years ago the Biden
Administration illegally spied on our
text messages and then leaked the
contents to their servants in the news
media they did this in order to stop a
Putin interview that we were planning
last month we're pretty certain they did
exactly the same thing once again but
this time we came to Moscow
anyway we are not here because we love
Vladimir Putin we are here because we
love the United States and we want it to
remain prosperous and free I can't wait
to watch it Tucker is already being
preemptively criticized for the
interview already there are political
cartoons about how he's a Putin puppet
and a Putin stooge and and whatever but
I don't really see why we would
preemptively attack him for even
conducting the interview plenty of
American journalists have interviewed
Vladimir Putin he's not the first one to
do it Megan Kelly interviewed Vladimir
Putin Barbara Walters interviewed
Vladimir Putin plenty of people have
done it over the years